und ihr Thema erfahren wollt könnte man
damit ja eigentlich ganz gut verknüpfen
dass vielleicht auch die Politik Fehler
macht
ja wir haben eine ganz Reihe von Fehlern
gemacht das ist wohl wahr und
in einer solchen Krise wird natürlich
das Vertrauen auf die Probe gestellt und
insofern ist es jetzt ganz wichtig
glaube ich dass dieses gehampelt was wir
jetzt hatten die jetzt Ampel Gehampel
dass das jetzt mal zu Ende ist
das reicht natürlich hinten und vorne
nicht wie bereits gesagt habe weil sie
müssen sehen dass draußen die
der Mittelstand und die Industrie jeden
Tag kämpfen um den Erhalt der
Arbeitsplätze und es wird in jedem Tag
schwerer gemacht da hilft uns nun schon
und das schafft auch ein bisschen Ruhe
die Ansage dass der Deckel bei Gas auf
12 Euro Cent festgesetzt wird und für
die Industrie auf 7 Euro Cent eigentlich
weil wie gesagt USA 3 € Cent oder 2 €
Cent und China 3 und gegen die treten
wir ja an das hat schon geholfen nur wir
müssen natürlich wissen dass am Ende wir
nicht jedes Jahr 200 Milliarden auf dem
Tisch legen können das wird dieser Staat
nicht aussagen das wird uns zu einer
Verschuldung führen dass wir
sozusagen an eine Weichwährung bekommen
mit dabei beitragen und deswegen müssen
wir dringend
die Angebote an Energie in Deutschland
verändern wir haben uns zu lange auf
Russland verlassen das war ja eine
Politik die die von grün bis schwarz
sozusagen angesagt war wir machen
Windenergie und jeder wusste hinter
jeder Windenergieanlage steht ein
Gaskraftwerk das muss es tun weil wenn
der Wind nicht da ist muss der Strom ja
auffließen also muss man flexible
Kraftwerke hinzuschalten können und das
war immer Gaskraftwerk das hat auch die
neue Ampel gesagt wir wollten 30
Gaskraftwerke bauen ja ich frage mich
woher und deswegen müssen wir die Frage
weiter ein tiefer stellen wir müssten
jetzt mal wirklich auch
in die in die eigenen
Erzeugungen herangehen das heißt das
Fracking was man machen kann in
Niedersachsen in Sachsen-Anhalt
Niedersachsen wird es jetzt nichts weil
da ist Rot-Grün dran da wird erstmal
fünf Jahre
keine neue technologische Innovation
angegangen ich sage auch die heimische
Braunkohle kann man grün machen man kann
das CO2 abschneiden das heißt das sind
die Aufgaben auch gerne energielaufzeit
verlängern wir müssen uns mit der
eigenen Braunkohle beschäftigen und sie
sauber machen das kann man nämlich der
norwegische Ministerpräsident hat uns
das angeboten hat gesagt ihr könnt das
CO2 zu mir geben ich bring das in die in
die Tiefsee und wir müssen das eigene
Erdgas fördern nur dann kommen wir raus
so dieses Gehampel man drei Monate
wieder mal ein bisschen Kernenergie und
dann gucken wir mal weiter das ist doch
keine Lösung das heißt wir müssen da wir
können dann 200 Milliarden rechtfertigen
wenn das eine Brücke ist in eine
Energiezukunft die wir dann wieder alle
Vertrauen haben
wenn ich jetzt hier so zuhöre muss ich
so ein bisschen denken die Regierung hat
den ernste Lage doch nicht erkannt
Grundwerk meine ich doch herrlich doch
der Ernst der Lage ist uns absolut
bewusst es geht um die
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit die internationale
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit der deutschen
Wirtschaft wir haben starken Mittelstand
und starken industriellen Mittelstand
eine Säule unserer Volkswirtschaft ist
die Industrie viel mehr als die USA das
beispielsweise haben oder auch andere
Länder und wir sind Exportweltmeister
wir sind abhängig von der
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit unserer Unternehmen
auf den Weltmärkten und wir sind in der
schwersten Energiekrise seit Bestehen
der Bundesrepublik da gibt es überhaupt
keinen Zweifel und ich stimme mir ein
paar Arnold ausdrücklich zu wenn er die
Frage aufmacht
wir haben doch Gas wir haben Gas in der
Nordsee wir haben Gasse in den Böden als
Schiefergas und wenn es zur Zeit hohe
Gaspreise gibt dann ist es auf jeden
Fall richtig zu untersuchen aber warum
sind diese Lösungsvorschläge da nicht
einfach umsetzbar fragt man sich jetzt
also erstmal wir haben einen gestörten
Markt wir haben eine energieschock und
das
verheiratet sich
mit mehr als zehn Jahren verschlafener
Energiepolitik das heißt also wir müssen
in weniger als einem Jahr reparieren was
über zehn Jahre lang so richtig schief
gelaufen ist und das wie gesagt in der
Kombination mit dem Schock dass Russland
nicht mehr liefert der Krieg die
zeitenwände
das bringt uns natürlich schon mächtig
unter Zeitdruck aber jetzt möchte ich
auch mal eine Lanze für die Regierung
brechen wir haben das mit der LNG mit
den beiden nlg-terminals in Rekordzeit
hinbekommen das Beschleunigungsgesetz
ist eine Blaupause für weitere ähnliche
Dinge um die Infrastruktur Vorhaben in
Zukunft viel schneller umsetzen zu
können Beschleunigung von Planungs- und
genehmigungsprozessen ist sah das
Stichwort und wir haben es immerhin
jetzt auch hinbekommen mit den Grünen
schwer genug haben wir diskutiert eine
Laufzeitverlängerung für die drei AKW
hinzubekommen und auch den Hochlauf von
Kohlekraftwerken das sind alles keine
Herzensangelegenheiten
Herzensanliegen der Grünen Partner
gewesen also von daher sind wir
pragmatisch wir sind schnell aber es
sind noch riesige Aufgaben um in 10 15
Jahren die brauchen wir nämlich um eine
Wasserstoffwirtschaft hochzufahren und
um tatsächlich Grenzkosten von 2-3 Cent
für die Kilowattstunde Erdgas geht
schnell aus dass wir wissen wo das
Erdgas liegt das könnte man machen habe
ich ja und haben sie zu Recht hier drauf
hingewiesen aber ich wundere mich schon
ich meine sie sind ja Parlamentarier es
ist eine angekommission eigentlich
gerichtet worden zum untersuchen ob
Fracking wirklich umweltschädlich ist
und das Ergebnis liegt seit einem Jahr
dem deutschen Parlament vor das wird
nicht debattiert dass der Deutsche
Bundestag debattiert das Ergebnis der
Experten nicht weil es unangenehm ist
das hat man ganz bewusst vor dem
niedersächsischen Wahlkampf rausgehalten
weil da kommt nicht dann bei raus dass
die Experten sagen das könnt ihr ruhig
machen das kann man nämlich beherrschen
dieses Thema Fracking in Deutschland
besser jedenfalls hier zu machen als
amerikanisches Fracking Gas zu
importieren und das hat der Deutsche
Bundestag das sind unsere Abgeordneten
nicht eigentlich mal zur Kenntnis
genommen da muss man doch mal wirklich
die Frage stellen die sie vorhin
gestellt haben kann man da wirklich
sagen haben die alles getan was nötig
ist sie sagen nein ja in dieser Frage
zum Beispiel ist ein Versagen des
Deutschen Bundestages da völlig klar und
die Opposition ich frag mich auch wo es
bleibt die denn ich meine da muss doch
mal Frieda
kämpft auf Twitter sehr hart ob das
jetzt was bringt für den Bürger weiß ich
nicht ganz aber auf Twitter sind die
sehr das Problem bei Friedrich Merz ist
doch dass er in seinem eigenen
adenauerhaus immer noch die Merkel Jahn
einer Überzahl hat und dass er sich
natürlich nicht so durchsetzen kann
offenbar wie es eigentlich nötig wäre
für eine Opposition die müssen doch
getrieben werden die Bundesregierung die
muss dafür einfach noch eine Opposition
die muss doch auch die unangenehm
Wahrheiten auf dem Tisch legen das ist
ein Punkt wo ja auch zwischen den beiden
einigkeit herrscht das in den letzten
zehn Jahren nicht alles richtig gemacht
wurde energiepolitisch und jetzt aber zu
Ihnen Herr Konrad ich komme hier
durcheinander drei Brillen drei Männer
die werden mich jetzt irgendwie
die Sache ist ja ganz klar die die
letzten zehn Jahre und auch schon davor
wurden ja Fehler gemacht in der
Energiepolitik ich denke keiner würde
mehr verteidigen dass wir komplett
abhängig von einem Partner waren
wie läuft das beim
Bundesnachrichtendienst wie kann man
sich das vorstellen hat man darauf
überhaupt Einfluss ist ein das schon
vorher bewusst geworden dass es
vielleicht Schwierigkeiten gibt ja
sicher das hat auch gestern insofern das
Timing sehr glücklich hat gestern der
BND-Präsident Bruno kahl auch sehr
deutlich in der öffentlichen Anhörung
gesagt wir ulco also der BND haben seit
Jahren darauf hingewiesen dass Sommer
Russland ein Problem ein
sicherheitspolitisches geopolitisches
Problem für Europa und eben für die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland wird und
schon vor 2014 darauf hingewiesen dass
eine Diversifizierung von
Energiebeschaffung etc pp notwendiger
allein nur aus dem
sicherheitspolitischen und darauf wurde
verstärkt hingewiesen darauf wurde
kontinuierlich ja das heißt
Berichterstattung auch in nd-lagen also
den dienstagslagen in die
Staatssekretäre zusammensitzen kam das
immer wieder aber
das nützt gar nichts wenn solche
Informationen und Bewertungen mit dem
penstown-syndrom verbunden werden das
heißt man legt den Stift hin sagt ja ja
das ist durchaus gegeben das hat der
Herr Karl gestern auch relativ deutlich
so als Frau Merkel darauf reagiert wenn
man es mal persönlich natürlich Frau
Merkel sondern die hat sich erst gar
nicht angehört nicht das sondern es hat
eben nichtmals angehört
man sich den Chef Bundeskanzleramt nicht
oder eben dann den Staatssekretär für
die Nachrichtendienste die es damals ja
in der Person von Herrn Fritsche noch
gegeben hat das heißt also die Frage ob
sie mit an welcomeus ja mit mit
unangenehmen Informationen ob sie dann
durchdringen oder aber eben durchaus
freundlich nicht auf Abstand gehalten
werden und wenn sie durchdringen denken
Sie daran sie müssten sich dann selbst
wenn sie es zur Kenntnis nehmen müssten
sie ja überlegen was sie mit dieser
Information anfangen das heißt also der
politische Willensbildung ja erst einmal
innerhalb der Exekutive dann aber
müssten sie ja gegebenenfalls die
politisch Willensbildung im Bundestag
oder zusammen mit der Wirtschaft von
Anfang einzuleiten nicht eine Kehrtwende
das wäre natürlich töricht sondern
schlicht und einfach eine stärkere
Diversifizierung
brauchen natürlich zum Beispiel auch
andere auch andere Anbieter noch mal
sondieren wir waren früher sehr stark
vom nahen mit Nordosten und Nordafrika
in
Energiezufuhr nicht abhängig aber das
waren gute Zulieferer Peter nehmen
abgestimmt Frau Merkel verteidigt ist ja
sogar noch heute also sie hat ja jetzt
auch wieder gesprochen sie das war ja
definitiv betrachtet was das günstige
Preis-Leistungsverhältnis wenn ich das
richtig sehe nicht so günstig sind wir
wir also Bundesrepublik Deutschland
sonst nie an energiegekommen
erdgast das durch eine Pipeline fließt
ist natürlich immer billiger als
Flüssiggas das hinterher regazifiziert
werden mussten und zwischendurch auch
gelagert und transportiert werden muss
aber es bringt natürlich auf beiden
Seiten Abhängigkeit also sowohl des
Anbieters als auch des Abnehmers ist
eine Abhängigkeit da weil man die
Pipeline nicht umzügeln kann ja die kann
man nicht woanders hinlegen also es gibt
nur einen Punkt wo es losgeht und ein
paar Punkte wo es daneben
sind jetzt in dem geopolitischen
Kontexte nicht mehr erwünscht nein Sie
müssen dringend überwunden werden
Russland ist im übrigen meiner Meinung
nach erledigt da werden wir nichts mehr
kaufen jedenfalls nichts was durch den
Pipeline fließt und andere
Abhängigkeiten wie beispielsweise mit
China
Gas aus Russland ich würde nie sagen
das ist nicht von der Landkarte
verschieben das wird ja da bleiben auch
da bleiben und im Augenblick macht
Russland folgendes sie nehmen von der
Yamaha das ist das Gebiet was uns
versorgt eine Pipeline Richtung China
eine power of sibiria direkt durch die
Mongolei nach China das heißt das wird
gar nicht mehr an uns ob wir überhaupt
haben wollen
das wäre wahrscheinlich auch langfristig
sag mal wenn wir Frieden haben und sagt
man danach Putin Ära mit Sicherheit
nichts dagegen wenn da aus einer
Pipeline Gas nach Europa wird weil wir
dann auch eine diversifizierte aller
Anbieter haben ich würde auch nicht
ungerne ich würde auch nicht gerne
alleine von Amerika abhängig sein sie
müssen wissen der beiden sagt wir stoppt
disstracking und Sie können Experten
befragen die sagen in drei vier Jahren
wird der amerikanische Fracking Gaspreis
so durch die
durch die Wiener Rakete nach oben gehen
ja weil keine neuen Felder mehr
erschlossen werden und was das
amerikanische
amerikanische Präsident dann machen wird
wenn die Gaspreise steigen in Amerika
und die die die die
Benzinpreise steigen das kann ich Ihnen
jetzt schon verraten der Stopp den
Export das wird das wird so kommen das
heißt auch das ist nicht so etwas wo wir
sagen können die guten Amerikaner die
helfen uns dann schon nee nee das wird
genauso ein Risiko werden einmal noch
konkret können Sie sich vorstellen ihre
Einschätzung her dass deutsche Industrie
ohne russisches Gas überhaupt auskommen
kann
also im Augenblick ist es tatsächlich so
dass wir nur deswegen durchkommen weil
wir diese
Subventionen bekommen und das wird sich
aber
die LNG Importe werden ein Viertel des
russischen Gas ersetzen können das wird
nicht hinten und vorne lang und deswegen
wird die Frage sich natürlich die
Hoffnung ist dass das dieser Konflikt
endlich in eine friedensrichtung geht
damit man auch wieder vernünftig
miteinander reden kann weil am Ende
glaube ich langfristig wäre es gut wenn
wir auch dieses Ei im Korb hätten und
nicht nur in amerikanisches und
algerisches oder sonst wie